warum hans denn wir überhaupt dieser
frage möchte ich jetzt auf den grund
gehen und zwar mit psychologe gottfried
barth von der uni tübingen guten morgen
sagen sie warum hamstern wir überhaupt
was bringt menschen dazu
guten morgen ich glaube da gibt
natürlich wie immer mehrere gründe und
es ist nicht bei allen menschen gleich
warum die hand
inzwischen hat man ein buch für man geht
es erfasst ein kleines stoff wer gewinnt
die verkäufe oder dann die hamsterkäufe
ließen die gärung regale schaffen
aber bei ihnen uns bei ihm heißt endlich
ist das recht der auf 805 und dieser
hintergrund der geht um ängste um
tiefsitzende ängste die beruhigt lagen
durch diese verkäufe und die ängste sind
natürlich im moment sehr klar kunden mit
dieser problematik
lassen sie uns mal genauer auf diese
ängste schauen die ängste dass nicht
genug klopapier für alle da sind diese
der unbegründet was für ängste spielen
denn da sonst noch alles für eine rolle
in dieser krise genau also mitten auf
zwei dinge begreifen warum gerade klug
auf bier
das liegt dann nicht unbedingt an den
ängsten können aber gleich darauf
zurückkommen
im moment gibt es berechtigte ängste ich
glaube wir sind dann immer wichtig in
unserer gesellschaft darin gelösten das
engste mit gesprungenen gibt es mehr
ausgegangen denn nie von servier karre
nicht wissen wie wichtig gehen wird und
diese fron ist die noch werfen das macht
uns auch ich habe angst dass ich nicht
weiß was in den nächsten wochen auch
nicht der hof licht und in meinem
senaten hilfe zu kommen
und ich glaube deswegen ist das so eine
stimmung aber wir sind nicht mehr
gewohnt offen mit diesen ängsten begehen
wir waren gewohnt und letztlich doch
noch der front wieder los und dann
würden sich die sucht büßten dennoch
nicht beruhigen können
haben sie denn noch tipps wie wir mit
dieser angst besser umgehen können mit
dieser angst dass unvorhergesehenes
nicht planbaren in diesen zeiten in
denen wir gerade leben der festlegung
ist natürlich ein problem denn das macht
er künftig dieser alles stellt dass man
sozusagen ein nicht versuchst du leugnen
und
das ist die grundlage rational zu
übernehmen was die die besten wege etwas
kommt
günstigen wege elektro möglichst gering
zu halten und dann glaube ich immer
natürlich gerne sehen das muss auch auf
der unser fragen wissenschaftler
versagen einsichtigen wieder in den
fachgebieten
und ein weiterer punkt aus meiner sicht
auch das sind die ängste dass man
community mit bewegen im besagten fällt
erstmal nichts zu tun hätte man im griff
achtens bewältigung dieser
toilettenpapier ist eine illusion das
wasserrecht die bedrohungen den griff
bekommen wenn wir die ängste teilen
können
vielleicht nur sagen dass ich mache ein
beruf in der psychiatrie psychotherapie
versprach ist die ängste das jetzt so
wichtig sind das rumpelstilzchen sind
gibt wenn man es nennen kann verwirft
beine macht
und dann sind wir gezwungen diese andere
wege die natürlich auch noch was tun
haben und zypern gibt was ich sagen na
ja an alles so passiert dass ich mit
aktionen mit den favoriten
ich würde noch sagen das sind so die
pistenregeln sie muss genommen haben
dass auf dem verglasten und ergänzt für
dinge wieder wachgerufen diesen
bestimmungen aber wenn wir damit umgehen
die ängste benennen die die realitäten
benennen und die guten wege versuchen zu
finden
dann ist bewegt
also offenbar kann uns der besitz von
genug lob ab im haus einen kleinen rest
sicherheit geben
herr gottfried barth vielen herzlichen
dank für ihre einschätzungen einen
schönen tag noch
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren